we're gathering they're trying to tell
me I got poor wireless connection
everybody's always criticizing man all
right here we go the last Jedi everyone
all weekend on Twitter and Instagram
Facebook own what the [ __ ] haven't you
seen the last job I haven't you talked
about it yet are you if I could talk
about of course I'm gonna talk about I
was busy this weekend I was out with Jay
and Colorado we were doing a tour for
the last 10 days and stuff so I saw the
movie on Friday set twice Saturday I we
had a show to do Sunday I was traveling
home and stuff now I'm home
I could breathe I put together all my
thoughts and I'm ready I'm ready kids
I'm ready to go over the last Jedi
you know the now people what you think
do I get it's no easy answer well yeah
there is an easy answer
[ __ ] of course I liked it and there's
definitely some stuff that we should
discuss are you here just let me set the
stage for you I saw last Jedi in Durango
Colorado in a gorgeous little - screener
theater old built before I was even born
and stuff like that so you know that new
seats pushback seaton but it was the
right environment instead of going to
like it multiplex or something like that
the I when I first saw Star Wars it was
on a - screener in New Jersey and hazlit
theater that don't exist anymore old - -
in Airport Plaza - screener so sat down
I said this is the right relationship
this is gonna be good to watch this in
here and you know I was blazed of course
before I went into the theaters Colorado
I mean but let's be honest no matter
where I was I was gonna be blazed but
there I was and a nice fantastic place
to receive this picture this motion
picture directed by Rian Johnson who
have spoken to on smoothie makers an old
podcast we used to do lovely guy he did
looper man which is a fantastic [ __ ]
movie as well as brick ryan was given
the the second of the new Star Wars
movies following JJ Abrams JJ as we now
know is doing the third one and he you
know had big shoes to fill because JJ
made the force
ken's force awakens like reintroduced
Star Wars to a whole new generation
people were largely happy made-up [ __ ]
ton of money
it's tough to follow that man tough
second act to follow
so did he do it I yes
is there stuff that I wish you hadn't
done of course
there usually is that in almost every
movie so I'm not gonna review I'm gonna
review the movie and then when it comes
time when I deviate from the film I'm
not saying this is what they should have
done or they focus uh hey man they made
choices in their story Tom I like a lot
of them some of them um baffled by but
the but but overall I respect their
vision when I jump it Ryan's vision and
all of Lucasfilm and Brian had a
co-writer as well I think I'm script
that being said periodically will hit
things where I'll tell you like now if I
was making a Star Wars movie and believe
me nobody's ever gonna let me make a
Star Wars movie those are the things
these are the the most of the things
that a tough time with things that I
personally would have changed in my own
version of a Star Wars movie as I'm sure
a lot of folks feel at home I saw a lot
of people on the internet getting
outraged about certain stuff toward the
end of the movie we'll get there and you
know that's all of us kind of reacted to
the movie we wanted to see the one
really great thing I could say about
last Jedi is didn't know where it was
going
every time I was just like well once or
twice she could kind of guess right
before something was gonna happen but
none of the things that I thought was
gonna happen happen and you know as an
audience member isn't that what you pay
for you go to a movie to be surprised
it's supposed to be like I noticed I
noticed I noticed so I was delighted on
that level but let me I'll tell you
about my - I'd saw the movie twice I
wrote down a [ __ ] ton of notes so I'm
gonna be reading the notes and stuff
like that
but let's dive into it my first viewing
was at noon my second viewing by myself
I mean there are other people in the
theater but not many it was not a
criticism of the movie or saying how it
did or anything obviously it did very
[ __ ] well this weekend it was just it
was early for some cats and Durango not
for me though I was up at like 9 o'clock
going where can we see this then I went
and saw it again at 7 o'clock at the
same Theatre with mr. Jason Mewes
sitting beside me to my left his first
viewing so here we go not all being said
that sets the stage I wrote down so I'm
go off the notes I wrote and there's a
[ __ ] ton of notes kids let me just tell
you many pages are so you could settle
in looks like I don't know they're not
numbered but it looks like a lot 1 2 3 4
5 7 [ __ ] at least 7 8 pages of notes not
single-spaced here we go
Star Wars last Jedi opening battle
sequence loved it
oh my lord I loved it this was actually
one of my favorite battles I've ever
seen in a Star Wars movie and and for
one like I'm just as a fan of the
franchise fan of anything a story is fun
somebody who likes being stories told to
them just show me something I haven't
seen before
that's all I'm looking for man something
I'm like wow and you know I've seen a
lot of Star Wars movies been seeing him
since I was 7 years old back in 1977 so
if you could show me something new
you got my loyalty man like remember we
also wrote one in the last minute we saw
some completely [ __ ] new version of
Darth Vader that we'd never seen before
in our lives man like forever the whole
mount hold my heart because that one
minute they showed me something new man
something and I was familiar with Star
Wars and still I was like this is
[ __ ] brand-new so in this scene is
very small but in this scene they showed
me something new which I absolutely love
poe takes out the last gun and then
skids to a halt in his x-wing by jamming
the Frogger and the expert goes boo so
he comes around and [ __ ] it's tiny
little things like that that make me go
like picking my nipples get all hard now
some people out there don't like this
movie oh you [ __ ] family yes yeah I'm
a fan boy I don't know if you've seen
those movies and whatnot I made we make
lots of references I literally eat Star
Wars food pop chips making bb-8 [ __ ]
snacks and [ __ ] like that I've you know
I had a big hand Solo in carbonite here
in the house when I was younger I got
Star Wars all over the place I'm in a
bag for this [ __ ] so he can't be there
like what could he's a fan yes of course
I'm a fan and that's a fan you show me
something new like Poe [ __ ] [ __ ]
skidding out and bringing that x1 around
right then and there I swear to god it
was one of the best watching this movie
the first time was one of the best times
I've had in a movie theater all year if
not in the last 10 years I was on the
edge of my seat I was smiling I was
crying
yes there
I saw an article online Cindy Kevin
Smith cried at last Jedi he did many
times I was thrilled I had to lay back
seat and I had to keep bringing a farm
so I was like no no and kind of getting
up in the face of the movie not angrily
but just like I was on the edge of my
seat so uh so uh you know that moment
you know you got to remember I just
smoked a joint just walked into the
theater I was snack free and [ __ ] like
that it just hit me so I'm like I've
never seen that like good for you right
and your friends and stuff you showed me
something [ __ ] bad-ass is something
new anyway the whole battle let me write
it down anyway opening battle sequence
as a resistance evacuates the base we
saw in the force awakens the first story
shows up the blasted to hell now in this
movie there are series I think Rian
Johnson's is a really nice guy and and I
know he is i sat here and talked to him
in shed but and I don't think he was in
any way I don't want anyone misconstrue
this I don't think he was attacking JJ
or force awakens but there are plenty of
what I like to call you JJ moments in
this movie where it seems like the you
know the work that was done in force
awakens just got [ __ ] undone in one
very quick spook by Ryan so again I'm
not saying Ryan says [ __ ] you to JJ for
realism joke but there are [ __ ] you JJ
moments in this movie the first one is
they blow that base to [ __ ] man as the
firt as the base that we saw on force
awakens where everybody was and where
they came back after Han got killed and
[ __ ] like that
so right off the top of this movie it's
like [ __ ] you JJ there goes your base
and the base goes away again I don't
think that's the ryan johnson said but
it was weird they really [ __ ]
disassembled a lot of [ __ ] in this movie
okay fantastic space battle that's why I
wrote down one of the best in Star Wars
Poe faces down hooks and right away we
get a flavor of the last Jedi
it's so weird they talked about like
they got rid of the guys that were
directing the han sol jung han solo
movie because though i gave man their
too jokey and so they went for broke
with the jokes in last Jedi and I for
one was on board I was not sitting there
going this is not a place when Poe is
gone like I'm holding for Hawkes and
Huck's gives his old will [ __ ] blow
yeah this guy we're gonna [ __ ] do
this wipe your ass over to galaxy what a
first order and then he's like still
holding for for IVA Hawkes Bobby Mann
sitting there
laughing this is this is new what a
weird direction to take you know it's
like the the closest thing to levity in
the in the first trilogy in the opening
was you know let's see
r2d2 and c3po on Tatooine going to
Jabba's palace and having a little
arguments with each other and get an
argument with the door and meeting good
morning guards and bib Fortuna and [ __ ]
like that so this was a legit like funny
opening man like and and pose they added
more tea they gave more time like more
to his character and you're like I like
this guy he's a lovable rogue and stuff
at least in the beginning it's later on
you're like what the [ __ ] though so in
any event I loved that scene Poe as I
said throwing his [ __ ] x-wing over
its kid now it's little things for being
men the Bombers versus the dread-nots
sequence where the Bombers bombed out uh
uh you know I've never seen these
bombers before it was awesome I was like
right on seemed a shame that so many
hoops blew up into each other and [ __ ]
like that but that happens when you war
on the stars that'll happen in the star
war so one bomber left I think the lady
was flying or was charged that roses
sister I think her name was Paige on
when they said fast they have this whole
like moment like where you know the
ships bombers blow up [ __ ] she's the
last bomb in the would [ __ ] drop your
bombs if again and the guy who's
supposed to drop the bombs the detonator
you know he can't [ __ ] he's out cold so
she got climb up there's long steps to
get it and stuff and you know it's a
wonderful little allegory for the one
you know the war comes down to one
person you hear many of these stories
from old war movies and from the actual
wars that have happened in real life and
stuff sometimes it comes down to the
hands of one person one lone person the
old war and take it out this dreadnought
which is posed big dream this big bomber
that could take it just BAM taking out
the base down below I'm JJ planet force
awakens plan pose like we gotta take
this [ __ ] out and Princess Leia's I
got no get back to the base I [ __ ]
told you know and he's like nine he told
turns his [ __ ] off of my knucks he wants
to take me if we take this bomber this
is a base killer or something like that
or [ __ ] resistance killer like we
take it out man we're [ __ ] taking
care of the future so he forgets his
commander general Leia's orders and he
goes for you know the kill and stuff so
in going for the kill they clear the
path for the bombers the Bombers in the
middle
the fighting and the TIE fighter hits
you know one boom it goes up and it
takes out like four others and [ __ ] all
the Bombers going to hell without ever
dropping the bombs I'm the dread nut so
it's left up to this this woman Paige
and she climbs upstairs and she gets the
detonator detonator
no she falls back this big blast and she
falls down below and so the detonators
still up top and in a very like that I'm
sure it's not certainly not taken from
this so please don't write Kevin Smith
thinks they still know but in a very
silent bob and Mallrats type moment
she's laying on the ground she like kind
of concentrates holds her necklace maybe
she suggested using the force of ever
and then you know kicks the the pole and
finally the detonator falls down she
catches it and then BAM she releases the
bombs it's cool I've never seen anything
like that before in a Star Wars movie
bombs away laser bombs and ship just BAM
and takes out the Dreadnought was a huge
celebration because it's like bigger
than the execution area you know the
[ __ ] Darth Vader's ship and [ __ ] the
Emperor ship whatever [ __ ] in in Return
of the Jedi an empire so you know big
sequence man really [ __ ] cool and
then Paige of course if that's her name
roses sister let's call her that she
goes up in smoke place blows up she gets
killed she goes out she's old not to
have her necklace
I'd be clearly you're like we're gonna
see the other half sooner or later and
we do later on okay
after that finn wakes up after getting
sliced up the back and force awakens man
he reconnects with Poe who gets slapped
and demoted by general lash like [ __ ]
off you disobeyed orders and she demotes
his [ __ ] ass then Finn ask Paul hey
man where's ray and that's when we
finally go looking on the race story
last time we saw ray she was on the
island she's looking for Luke Skywalker
she went to Luke Skywalker Island Scott
Skyland she went the Skywalker Island
Skyland fuel and she's on Skyland and
she's like yeah here's your [ __ ] dick
back join those Star War [ __ ]
and that's how the movie ended this is
like the [ __ ] felt like huge AJ
moment in the movie where the ending of
force awakens is predicated on this one
shot of Rey handing Luke his lightsaber
back here's your metal dick [ __ ] bi
and you know Mark Hamill who's wonderful
in the movie tremendous it was so nice
to see him back I mean we saw him for a
brief moment the last one
you gotta remember this is the first
time we've seen Luke Skywalker and
earnest for a lot of screen time since
your turn the Jedi was [ __ ] thrilled
and I know the guy in real life so I was
thrilled for him and just like hey if I
could I like this story but as a fan
going back I was just like there he is
it's Luke gasps he looks like Grizzly
Adams now but we're gonna spend some
time hearing from old Luke Skywalker and
stuff who's now like old like Ben Kenobi
was old so I was I was so in the tank
for this so we meet him and instead of
like you know oh my god here's my dick
back and time to [ __ ] [ __ ] the star
war he just throws the lightsaber of
their shoulder very cavalier man felt
like a real big [ __ ] you JJ moment again
not like seriously like we a jay-z but
it this movie last Jedi dismantles a
bunch of things from force awakens and
some could make the argument dismantles
things going further back to George
Lucas land the force is now something
completely different and I'm actually
down with it alright so let's see uh
knock - that's the that's theme of the
island Skyland we'll call it Scott
Walker island scotland Luke wostow
parties
sequels man he's like [ __ ] this you go
back home and you tell people I'm done
[ __ ] finished [ __ ] like that and so
he he goes and hides in this little hut
which I called Java when I watched it
he's living in Jabba though in any event
it's bad pun ray wants him to come back
and fight in the Star War but Luke says
what do you think's gonna happen man you
think I'm gonna face down the
first-order with a laser sword and I
gotta be honest with you I bumped into
that in a weird way this is one of those
moments where if I was making this movie
you know one laser sword nobody's ever
said that in the Star Wars universe
I don't think lasers like laser sword
was the name of the off-brand lightsaber
that when your mom was like I'm not
buying you that Kenner lightsaber it's
ten dollars you can have the laser sword
brand and which is just the like the
flashlight with a plastic tube on and
[ __ ] cost like two bucks so it was very
weird to hear that term I bumped into
that not in a way whereas I [ __ ] this
movie I was like Luke Skywalker just
said laser sword he he called it the
generic brand but you know
lightsabers the brand name it's like
band-aid lightsaber band-aid we all know
it's a laser sword technically but light
saber is its
name particularly in the Star Wars
universe so to hear Luke Skywalker
referred to his lightsaber a lightsaber
as a laser sword even though you know I
get it he's like I'm done with this [ __ ]
I'm over the [ __ ] Star Wars leave me
alone one of my [ __ ] milk sea cows
and [ __ ] eat fish I get it
hearing him say laser sword was like
just strange to me it was the it was it
was if as if Rey was like I'm caught and
Luke was like I will get you an adhesive
strip you know instead of saying
band-aid it was just very weird moment
you know didn't ruin the movie but I was
like lasers anyway back to this man
that's when Chewie busts in man comes
through the door and [ __ ] but and like
that door really could have hit Luke Oh
said well maybe not because he's the
force but I was like I was close Chewie
and so Hans and Luke is like Chewie what
are you doing here and stuff and he's
like hey man where's you know a race
like we're here in the Falcon we've come
to take you back to the Star Wars your
sister and he goes white wait popkins
here where's Han and right then and
there you're like here we go no [ __ ]
tell me you know why he's gonna get on
that [ __ ] plane gonna find out his
bestie got killed by his nephew by his
besties own son and he's gonna be like I
will avenge thee or you know bring him
to justice or [ __ ] bring him back to
the light side whatever the [ __ ] but you
would imagine that's the scene man like
you're gonna hear Luke Skywalker you're
gonna watch Luke Skywalker have to hear
about the death of Han Solo from this
woman he just met ray and from Chewie
and he can understand Chewie Chewie is
like he's like I don't know so he could
clearly understand Wilke so I mean again
I what they did in the movies fine they
set it up the great cross-cut moment
where you know he goes wait a second
where is Han and then he crossed cut to
kylo Ren the Han killer man he follow
his story but if I was making the star
war and nobody again I'm not saying mine
would be better this is my own personal
[ __ ] last Jedi
Kev's last Jedi I you know I might have
gone for it man I might have had Chewie
do a whole monologue just tell the
[ __ ] story of han Solo getting killed
by his own son and getting emotional
remember like [ __ ] Chewie and on
Empire when they close the doors and
[ __ ] when they left town outside so I
was just something I thought
like stone and later on I was like I
would have been badass to watch a
[ __ ] bookie monologue my people might
laugh the audience but if you if he's a
motive enough and you put in that
[ __ ] John Williams score and [ __ ]
lots of strings that's not jerking off
that strings you know and [ __ ] like
you're seeing and that gives mark a
chance
select [ __ ] ammo because he's the
only guy could understand the [ __ ] of
wookie we can't the audience but it
would have to play out and in marks
performance and he even watch him like
suddenly well up and [ __ ] weep as
he's hearing a wookie telling the story
of what happened to his bestie and the
Wookiees bestie anyway [ __ ] my version
they didn't do that they crust cut right
over to kylo Ren so we get into the kylo
Ren story and let's see kylo Ren gets
bitch-slapped by Snoke in the Red Room
in the Red Room with black flooring
surrounded by red guards man and the
[ __ ] Snoke is dressed in gold LeMay I
don't know why
odd choice booze totally fine but I was
like that's weird never seen much gold
in this picture except gold leaders to
anybody
we crossed cred over there and and yeah
Snoke is telling [ __ ] kylo Ren you're
an emo [ __ ] and your [ __ ] boy and a
mom you know and that [ __ ] hit him
hard and [ __ ] and that leads so kylo
[ __ ] bust out of there and he's like
[ __ ] dest he gets into an elevator and
destroys the kylo Ren mask equivalent to
Anakin Skywalker ripping off his helmet
and then breaking that up and I'm done
with this yet deal with this you know
granted Adam driver is far more
attractive as as kylo Ren as you know
old burnt scarred up burger Schachter
who played you know Anakin Skywalker and
returned the Jedi maybe was whatever but
you know is it Darth Vader mask cool
image I understand what they did where
they're like let's get Carlo out of this
[ __ ] mask gives you know the actor
like look at my face and shake gives him
a chance to a moat and and I like this
dude I didn't want really saw that TV
show that he was on so [ __ ] these are
discover to me I'm like this guy's dope
they do have him shirtless in the movie
at one point that was a big discovery as
well but in any event so he's all mad
third [ __ ] you JJ moment feels like and
maybe it's not [ __ ] you JJ it may be
[ __ ] you force awakens the FY f a moment
if you will kylo Ren smashes his mask
like all the marketing and the toys is
kylo Ren with a mask in the
best movie and stuff and he's like I'm
jr. Darth Vader so I wear this mask and
you know Ryan's like no you're not that
she smashes the fight of Ryan writes
that he smashes the mask
guess what kylo Ren gets rid of his
[ __ ] mask so suddenly he's maskless
another [ __ ] you force awakens moment
okay let's see what else do I got back
to the planet - Luke - a Skyland - Luke
Island Luke still won't deal with Rey
who follows him around on the island
average day mobile space walruses
catching fish we meet the pork man which
are neither in walks nor Jar Jar that I
thought they were lovely they you know a
lot of people online were like he's
[ __ ] pores but they're not ruin the
movie I thought they were used to the
perfect extent they were just background
coloring man like hey I'm this island
they got these [ __ ] penguin looking
birds big eyes and [ __ ] and and when
they did use them I thought they used
him effectively I know a lot of people
saw the trailer and when she was like
her and the Falcon the poor's like
everyone's like [ __ ] this but I honestly
thought the porns worked out man I
thought they were good inclusion
particularly because it led to like one
of the funniest moments in any Star Wars
movie I've ever seen which we'll get to
later on okay [ __ ] it we'll get to it
now remember like at one point in the
movie choose going to eat a [ __ ] you
know poor you grab the poor he cooked it
they didn't show that part but as he's
about to eat it looks like a little fry
a little cooked chicken rotisserie
chicken all these pores are staring at
him like he's horrified eyes and [ __ ]
like no and they'll use a good nail
scatter and then one is still hanging
out and [ __ ] and like make up the movie
you want your head but in my room in my
mind I'm like it's his mother she was
about to eat his roasted mother and the
poor gizzard
so somehow I think them in my movie
they're the ones that became friends
later on because choo he's like sorry
Chewie didn't eat the thing though
Chewie goes vegan in this movie I
believe very forward-thinking and stuff
but it but pores were worth it just for
that alone I also thought they were just
cute and again they were not invasive
it's not like the port's saved the
[ __ ] third act they save that for the
silver foxes okay here we go
Luke boards the Falcon he finally you
know I have to raise bugging him for a
few days like train me come back
whatever the [ __ ] he's like [ __ ] off he
goes out in the cover of night while Chu
is trying to eat pores and not
succeeding and he goes on the Falcon
we've seen this moment from the trailer
and it's
beautiful like P and I start crying in
that moment I'm like oh my god he's home
look at him and he's touching the dice
like I'm getting emotional thing about
now that it was beautiful but they did
it one better cuz I was wondering like
what is that moment when I saw the
trailer is he getting on the Falcon for
the first time they about to leave the
island and [ __ ] but he was looking
around and then he bumps into r2d2 and I
honestly feel like and I'll probably
[ __ ] prod talking about this may be
the emotional highlight of the movie
I'll try to get through this without
getting weapon but we all of us have
gone on this adventure for what 40 years
I'm doing this [ __ ] since I was seven
years old talking about Star Wars for
one reason only because Luke's well you
know George because George Lucas had a
good idea but really if you look at it
through the movie we went on this
adventure because a boy on a farm met a
robot that he wasn't supposed to meet
who was there by total [ __ ] accident
or chance unless you know the force but
I don't think so the droids escaped from
the rebel blockade runner land on
Tatooine get picked up by Jawas as all
in Star Wars of course and then Luke and
his uncle you know go buy some [ __ ]
droids and they want one of them they
don't even try to buy our to do - they
try to buy our 5d for and he [ __ ]
blows up and [ __ ] and so that names like
will [ __ ] take this one we're on this
journey all of us because because that
little droid now know it's very
fashionable now to be like hey bb-8
rocks and [ __ ] r2d2 socks because
he's old-school and [ __ ] but it all
begins with them like r2d2 is kind of
Luke's heart don't [ __ ] embarrass me
is a really big moment for me so he
talks to to r2d2 and you know r2d2 like
yeah just like I was saying oh my god
Chewie could have told [ __ ] Luke the
story they did to kind of do that scene
with r2d2 where Luke is talking to r2
and he's like no I'm not going back man
there's nothing in the world that
anybody could do to make me go back and
r2 projects the image the the message oh
my god I can't believe him look at 47
that's gonna make me cry r2d2 projects
the message that Luke saw as a youngster
will help me well be one kenobi your mom
Oh in the theater dude I was like I was
worse than this I was bawling wiping my
eyes and my [ __ ] popchips and [ __ ] it
was that was perfection that was so good
I mean [ __ ] like call back naturally I'm
a fan so I like any reference to the old
movies but I was so well written man to
bring that back in holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you know Luke was just like man that's
low blow you had to pull that [ __ ] out
again we're only on this adventure
because that little droid showed him
that [ __ ] video and for them to bring
it back
I was excellent just so excellent there
is looking at last time you saw that
video she was some space princess and he
was in [ __ ] farmville and he's like
oh my god I could [ __ ] go up to outer
space and join the star war and [ __ ]
like that fight with the rebels against
the Empire now he's looking at this
video as an old man and that's his
sister and he's gone on this incredible
40-year journey and become a Jedi
[ __ ] master because of that video
excellent writing pulling that out
[ __ ] perfection I absolutely love
that um let's see the idea of tracking a
ship through hyperspace through the jump
through Hyper's through a Lightspeed
jump that's new they've never done that
before
that leaves the resistance no choice but
to lead the first door on a slow chase
across the galaxy until they run out of
gas if somebody once told me the plot of
the next Star Wars movie would be this
very slow freeway chase I'd be like no
no that sounds like something I'd write
well and I know they did it and it's
nothing wrong with it but I was like
that's interesting I thought I'd see
that mister was moving it did remind me
of something though I don't think it's
taken from this at all but I remember
there was an episode of Battlestar
Galactica the new one where they had to
keep jumping like every 20 minutes or
every hour because the Cylons had locked
on to them and so everywhere they jump
boom the Cylons would be behind them
they'd have to keep [ __ ] jump and
they're run out of energy
I don't know again I'm not saying they
took that I was just remembering that it
reminded me of that a little bit but
anyway I didn't I didn't mind it I was
like right on there's they got a lot of
they're juggling a lot of balls in this
movie and I don't mean that in a dirty
way and a lot of different storylines so
one of the storylines is this man are
they gonna run out of gas and [ __ ] like
that weird but I'll take it and it's
well done well made okay kylo Ren attack
the resistance fleet after gets bitched
out by Snoke he's like fog you get my
ship and he's like we know where the
[ __ ] resistance R is I'm gonna kill
him all right now because I'm no boy in
a mosque and so he [ __ ] jumps on his
[ __ ] he's got TIE fighters [ __ ] with
him and shade he's got like a Darth
Vader look at TIE fighter he is the
ultimate Darth Vader fanboy and he's you
see the moment from the trailer we're
like don't [ __ ] tell anybody mind you
all of this of course is spoilers
hopefully everyone who realized this is
a spoilers I know I'm a little deep into
it to say spoilers but 27 minutes in
[ __ ] heavy spoilers so he's about
he's like do I do it and they cut to
Ladd she senses maybe they don't
directly but it looks like she senses
that he's out there and she's wondering
if he's gonna shoot wasn't the exact
read of it but just like you know they
cross cut between them and he's like do
I do it and then you see his finger go
down and then he's like [ __ ] he don't
do it and then BOOM two [ __ ] shots
come from the side his size his two
wingman they're like [ __ ] I'm Shae my
mama she's my mother [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] blow to [ __ ] the ship to
kingdom come and you watch Princess Leia
Carrie Fisher get blown out into [ __ ]
space and I literally did this [ __ ] that
like cleaned all the way far was like
whoo this is how it's gonna happen like
you know sadly we lost Carrie so they
had to adjust the storyline somehow
because they said she Princess Leia
wouldn't necessarily be in the next Star
Wars movie and I said this is bold cuz
this is like a first half hour of the
movie has oh my lord
and then something happened which seemed
to pissed off a lot of people on the
internet I went with it because I was
just thrilled as an old timey Star Wars
fan who saw Return of the Jedi in a
theater and you know Yoda said there you
know at the end of empire there's
another and then he [ __ ] finds out
that it's his sister we never seen
Princess Leia general Leia Organa get to
use the force necessarily she could hear
Luke and stuff connect with Luke at the
end of Empire a little bit in jeddah I
think if I remember correctly but this
was we got to watch general light we got
to watch leia princess leia my first
love save herself with the [ __ ] force
now
she had to turn him to Space Ghost and
fly throughout his face to do it that
seems to have pissed off a great deal of
the audience there's some cats who are
like lay I can't do that the force can't
do that well I mean let's be honest the
force does whatever whoever writes and
directs this [ __ ] each year says it does
so now the force can give you a little
forcefield and you could breathe kind of
like in guardians of the galaxy when
Peter gets that thing and remember yondu
puts about him he's cover he's a guy so
there was an outer space near death
scene that might arrival that but she
saved herself she comes flying through
outer space and [ __ ] in her gown and you
know again I was like hey man princess I
used the force of pretty badass would I
have done the space thing likely not but
you know I was there but I also see the
consternation online with like you
bucket jerk she space walked amen
like there's a lot of wonderful to [ __ ]
in this movie can't quibble with it all
okay so let's see Finn wants to get off
the ship and he finds Rey so he could
find ray so he use his latest tractor
leg give ray a tracker space tracker and
he found after the space Leia came back
and they put her in a sickbay he found
the tracker on the ground so he's like
[ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] track down right
remember that's his buddy that they came
together Finn is the stormtroopers like
[ __ ] this and you didn't mean to be her
hero he's just a guy he's technically a
[ __ ] deserter of the first order and
stuff and it worked out on Starkiller
base and he's something rockstar as we
find out because he's trying to leave to
try to take that tracker getting an
escape pod he meets his woman named ROS
her sister Paige was involved with a
figure name is Paige was involved in the
[ __ ] Star War with the bombs and [ __ ]
so she's like oh my god it's you you're
you're Finn everybody knows you like
he's [ __ ] famous because of what he
did with the empire cuz he left them
she's like you're the stormtrooper that
left and you help brings down Starkiller
base
she's a very fun scene not like goofy
but is sweet like he's famous in their
world and she's like wow and then she
kind of pieces together he's trying to
[ __ ] escape an escape pod and [ __ ]
like that a deserter and so she shocks
the mouths because she had said like I
had to take out a few people who trying
to jump ship she realizes that this guy
her hero is actually one of them [ __ ]
and then you know she's about to turn
him into the bridge
whatever space jail and you know they
have this conversation about hey man how
are they tracking us in space that she
can't be done she's like unless it was
done on a suborbital wave the two-brains
so they start thinking the same and
they're like oh [ __ ] I bet you we could
[ __ ] stop this tracking we just need
to go tell somebody and [ __ ] like that
so they wind up teaming up becoming
becoming a pals and so let's go [ __ ]
talk to somebody all we need to do is
get on snoke ship as if it's like that
[ __ ] simple
they tell PO and then all three of them
do a FaceTime with Maz Kanata who's busy
elsewhere she turns him on to a guy on
canto bright I think it is a casino
planet that like looks like Monaco if
you don't know what Monaco is it looks
like Iron Man 2 in the beginning when
whiplash shows up that's how I know [ __ ]
I never been to Monaco but I've seen it
in movies including Iron Man 2 okay so
there's a very funny spin on the like
you'll never see a more wretched hive of
scum and villainy as they're coming into
canto bright Rose is just like it's
filled with the worst kind of people and
they cut to rich people which I thought
was kind of funny man like people who
are obviously well-to-do and they're in
Star Wars [ __ ] uniforms and makeup
and [ __ ] like that so it's like the
cantina scene in Star Wars but with
[ __ ] rich people instead of you know
a wretched hive of scum and villainy
which was more of all Mos Eisley
but anyway so you're seeing rich people
for the first time in Star Wars we've
seen money in Star Wars are big crates
with money in it like when [ __ ] Han
got paid at the end and [ __ ] like that
of Star Wars before he came back to save
the day
so money is a factor in this universe
but it's never really like you know you
don't really see it or whatever you get
to see lots of [ __ ] Imperial coinage
or first-order coinage and said [ __ ] a
lot a lot of little things they're
trying to stick money into BBA which
felt a little little comfortable but
also like hey man that's what they do in
Star Wars I'm like you know sometimes
little things [ __ ] talk to you they
Lucas that moment a little bit mixi no
anyway so these two park illegally Finn
Andros and because of that they get
arrested they're trying to find this
guy's got a bloom on his lapel he'll be
the master code breaker that's what Mass
told him like this guy I mean he's the
man he'll get you on a [ __ ] Snoke
[ __ ] this is the only guy so they don't
get to that guy they get thrown
[ __ ] space jail disney jail and while
they're there they meet Benicio del Toro
who's like hey man I'm Code Breaker I'm
a Code Breaker - I've been doing this
for years and he opens their jail cell
and lets them all out first he's like
you want my help like now we're good and
then he lets him out of cell and they're
like holy [ __ ] so they all wind up
breaking up and Benicio del Toro he
winds up with [ __ ] bb-8 PPA didn't
capacitated a bunch of casino jail
people guards cops casino cops
and then finn and rose there with a you
know earlier and you know they were on
the platform canto brett and heard a lot
of fun during footprints and it was like
these tongs on looking creatures you
know again in my version they would have
been top dogs but you know i'm stupid so
they had these like horses instead look
like that people face it didn't have
long horse steps these animals that get
raced on
they're like racing horses and so you
know they saw there's quick shot and
being abused and stuff and so rose you
know has the warm wonderful idea of like
let's [ __ ] get rid of them she don't
say that she doesn't say look let's let
him out but the casino cops come in
Allston the cages open up the [ __ ]
horses go running i mean is there's a
very vegan and animal friendly influence
running throughout this entire movie
which i thought was very sweet I lived
with a the biggest animal lover on the
planet in this house who's also a vegan
so I when I saw the movie afterwards I
was like you I texted my daughter you
are gonna [ __ ] love how much they
love the animals of this movie they
won't even eat a [ __ ] pork so in any
event these horse creatures go running
free and [ __ ] like that and they're on
their back of one of them and then the
casino cops are chasing them and [ __ ]
and and you know the horses can run up
mountains and [ __ ] and they finally get
away and she takes the saddle off one of
the horse and you know they say like we
didn't get the guy then goes like this
is [ __ ] you know we didn't find the
guy and stuff like that and so you know
after they released the horses that's
when that's when she the RO says now it
was worth it like they did something
they accomplished something they're not
just like look at all the [ __ ] rich
people and she'll like that
they set the horses free so meanwhile
Laura Dern we meet Laura Dern man after
Prince's leg goes out we got Laura Dern
who's playing a meal in a melon
jamie-lynn hold though I write about her
in the princess item Rita it was read to
me in the audiobooks over on audible.com
there's a Princess Leia backstory book
and they introduced this character so I
know a little bit about them their
friendship and where they came from
because all of a sudden they just
introduced her in this movies like
here's Britain's last friend you never
heard of a meal in hold oh and it's
Laura Dern and purple [ __ ] hair and
she takes over because general Leia has
compact incapacitated aft of space fly
space ball so most of the hot-headed Poe
he just wants to blow [ __ ] up like you
don't want to like you know wait and
[ __ ] and hold those like we're just
gonna hold our course stay the course
and he's like nah we gotta blow [ __ ] up
so you can see they're gonna start
coming to loggerheads Poe
he runs the Finn Andros mission to canto
bright behind her back behind Admiral
hold those back and stuff meanwhile we
find out that Rey remember and kylo Ren
remember him they have a connected
there's a lot going on in this movie man
so I had to write [ __ ] down they got a
forced connection they could talk to
each other and [ __ ] like that and see
each other and at one point you know
he's like kylo ren's like you can't be
doing this if you did this [ __ ] it would
tear you apart because she's young Jedi
Knight stuff sets it up for something
that will happen in the third act so you
know they think they're just like
they've got this bond they start talking
to each other like a couple teenagers
know where you from
aren't you kill you dad [ __ ] why'd
you do this and he's like hey man you're
like [ __ ] what your parents ever do
for you and [ __ ] like that so they start
talking he's trying to pull her to the
dark side she trying to pull him to the
light side and stuff meanwhile Luke's
telling her about the force he's gone
forget the [ __ ] force man there's one
really funny moment where she's sitting
on the rock he's like no reach out and
she's supposed to reach out with her
feelings instead she reaches out with a
hand he takes a piece of grass or like a
[ __ ] stem of a plant he starts
rubbing her hand she's like do you feel
that she goes I do I do feel it and he's
like the force this is really funny like
it sir what he's like I don't reach out
that way you idiot and so he's telling
her to reach out like her feelings and
[ __ ] like that and so she sees
everything life death how it's all
connected and blah blah and the theory
of the force in this movie is Luke says
the force is not for the Jedi it's not
like if the Jedi died of light goes out
of the universe it's like [ __ ]
that's arrogance that's all
and stuff forces does not belong to the
Jedi nor does it belong to the set he so
you know what the force is he's like
it's that [ __ ] in between love and hate
it's the [ __ ] in between war and peace
that night and day whatever the [ __ ] is
the the glue the cartilage that holds it
together which isn't far from like it
flows through us it binds us together is
what Ben Kenobi said it you know it's an
interesting idea it's like the force is
not good and or bad it just is and it
could be you know people can lean in a
direction and [ __ ] like that interesting
theory
so Rey is powerful she can see all the
[ __ ] then she goes right to this dark
hole on the island the glory hole
[ __ ] seaweed on it and she's like
what is this something in there and he's
like you went for the [ __ ] dark hole
I was seen that happen once it was with
kylo Ren and he's like I don't want work
with you no more he's done trust her and
[ __ ] because he thinks she might be evil
or whatever the [ __ ] or him being
brought to the dark side let's see uh
she goes into that hole benches she's
talking to [ __ ] kylo Ren you know
doing the [ __ ] texting with their
minds and she's like I went in the hole
[ __ ] and I saw myself reflected a
hundred and seventy eight times and I'd
snap and then we'd all snap and and then
finally I got up to a magic mirror and I
said show me my parents and they showed
me me like that was it did one of those
scenes kind of like an empire where Luke
goes and the tree wants up fighting
himself but you know in the tree at
least you really [ __ ] Darth Vader I
was a nine years old when I saw or ten
nine or ten nine on the verge of ten
when I saw him Park Strikes Back and
then that scene where Luke you know he's
like what's in that tree and Yoda is
like oh you got her find out he's like
what's in there and he's only what you
take with you and salute brings the
lightsaber and [ __ ] and then Vader shows
up as a child I was like Vader's i dag
about he's a [ __ ] tree but it was like
a fantasy I didn't understand that I was
a [ __ ] child
this one I understood you know this one
I was like ya know I'm pretty sure this
is one of those fantasy type things and
so in any event Luke strain and Rey
finally to [ __ ] embrace the force and
[ __ ] after [ __ ] r2d2 game [ __ ] [ __ ]
he was like yeah I guess I should help
so he's a cop trainer and [ __ ] we
learned what happened with Luke and kylo
Ren Ren in like three different versions
of story basically Luke knew kylo Ren
was already in league with Snoke and so
one night he's standing over him in his
[ __ ] Hut
and he's like who what his kid's gonna
be the next Darth Vader and he [ __ ]
snaps on his lightsaber and then you
know we hear it's a couple different
versions of the story but the ultimate
version is then he was just like I can't
do that I'm [ __ ] Luke Skywalker I
can't kill kids this is [ __ ] nuts man
that's an Anakin Skywalker thing he was
the one killing younglings yep I'm not
gonna do this but before he could turn
his [ __ ] off he's already feeling shame
kylo Ren wakes up Ben solo his nephew
sees his [ __ ] uncle standing over him
with his [ __ ] you know glowing metal
kill stick out and it's like [ __ ] and he
[ __ ] pulls his lightsaber and [ __ ]
goes to attack and Luke blocks it and
then kylo Ren brings the ceiling down on
Luke and then there's the moment we saw
him Force awakens when Rey was in the
room and touched the lightsaber where we
see Luke's hand on our to head and [ __ ]
like that we saw a different angle of it
because kylo Ren went apeshit killed all
the other [ __ ] Jedi trainees and
burned the temple down and stuff which
will teach you to not stand over your
[ __ ] nephew in the middle of the
night with you know a little Ike saber
you know granted you could make the
argument Emma and snow could already
tournament [ __ ] like that but you know
if I woke up and I was like oh
Luke was gonna kill me [ __ ] this and
bringing it down and that's what he did
so you know raised like hey man like you
got to be better she's trying to pull
him to the light side and [ __ ]
Luke's bummed about being a Jedi in this
movie he wants it all then Daz we saw in
the trailer she's like it's time for the
Jedi to end and he catches Rey and kylo
force touching each other in a hut man
and blows the [ __ ] roof off and then
he's like Bob told you talk to that boy
which I thought was like gonna be
eventually Luke saying because he's your
brother and I think that's you know
maybe what we were set up to believe in
stuff that the relationship because from
the last movie wrote who is Ray and how
does she figure into the Skywalker saga
she of Kenobi what is her relation to
all this and stuff so in that moment I
was like maybe that's why he's mad that
they're [ __ ] touching each other
force touch and her [ __ ] chitchat
because he's like you're a man I know
from kissing my sister and then finding
out she's your sister let me spare you
the [ __ ] heartbreak of kids and your
brother and finding out who's your
brother or something later on so she
don't matter they wanted to fight and
she attacks him with her stick and he
[ __ ] pulls a stick from the sky and
you get to see Luke Skywalker fight for
a little bit then she [ __ ] gets a
drop on him with a lightsaber and [ __ ]
and that's when he's like this ain't
gonna go to way you think from the
trailer and whatnot and you know she's
like you got a [ __ ] help are you
gonna help her not wasting my time and
it's on you could take your metal dick
back and [ __ ] fight the force of the
first order and he's like no he's just
[ __ ] looks down and she's like fine
I'm gonna then I got to go to kylo Ren
I'm gonna try to turn him there's good
in them and you won't help me [ __ ] it I
got to do something here and she takes
off she takes Chewie in r2 takes the
Falcon [ __ ] off and Luke watches him go
and then he's all mad at himself so goes
the lights [ __ ] lighter heavy-duty
lighter and he goes to burn down this
tree on the islands got the sacred Jedi
texts and stuff he's like done with this
[ __ ] things you see him climbing the
stairs to the tree we go behind you were
panning or [ __ ] darling and wind up
going behind very familiar ahead instead
of years and this is another highlight
of the movie for me because again it's
very easy to put together any time you
let the old characters talk to each
other you got my full attention and
there it was Yoda and hats off to Ryan
and and the production folks for
choosing the Yoda they chose it was the
Yoda who dies and returned the Jedi
we've seen Yoda and the prequels they've
done Yoda as a version of puppets
remember in the first in the The Phantom
Menace he was a puppet at first and then
later on George Lucas I think change
amounts of digital then he was digital
you know for the rest of those movies
and stuff so we haven't seen like
hardcore puppet Yoda not that one
particularly since his death and they
brought that one back the same Yoda that
died and returned the Jedi and then the
blanket falls down that's the one that
comes back to see Luke and it's [ __ ]
beautiful man like you know he calls him
young Skywalker
I'm such an easy mark that's what he
used to call a return job and he'll
always be young Skywalker didn't even
though we're sitting there going young
Skywalker [ __ ] this guy is old
and they have a chitchat he's like I'm
gonna burn two bucks and he's like [ __ ]
you I'll do it he calls down some
[ __ ] lightning and it lights the tree
up and [ __ ] and he said what are you
doing and he's just like [ __ ] the
books don't matter that she's gone like
you ever tried to read them they're not
page-turners he's like you know to force
and the Jedi's are inside of you or some
[ __ ] touchy-feely [ __ ] and he talks
about like he how you know Luke feels
like a failure like Luke has thrown
himself in exile because he goes of what
happened with kylo Ren he's just like
I'm [ __ ] terrible Jedi Master I'm an
idiot why did I ever try I shouldn't
touching the forest and [ __ ] he's
disconnected from the force and Yoda is
like you don't get it you're you did
exactly what you're supposed to do you
trained him and and good and bad it's
all part of it he says something very
similar to what I was saying stage where
I'm like failure is just success
training I know it sounds like a cat
poster but it's [ __ ] true and he says
something about like failure is a great
teacher or some such [ __ ] and he's like
you you taught that dude like you did
what you're supposed to and he's like
all students move beyond the masters of
a certain point you know so it kind of
lets Luke off the hook Luke's been
beating the [ __ ] out of himself for
years and stuff he's like come on man it
was the it was the Good Will Hunting
it's not your fault will moment with the
you know Shawn it's not your fault
it wasn't like Luke oh [ __ ] you Shawn
not you but he was just like wow and
Yoda's gone [ __ ] the past in some
degree of it think about the future and
[ __ ] books are books man he's going to
Jedi that's in you or whatever [ __ ] but
it was a really beautiful moment and and
there's Mark Hamill acting with like the
puppet that he acted with I don't know
it's the same puppet probably a new
version of it but you know from years
back is beautiful wonderful moment and
and smart that Yoda was the guy who had
to come to Jesus conversation with him
and and you know in the back of my mind
when the movie star I was like I wonder
if they'll show Yoda and then when it
happened I'd completely forgotten I
wasn't expecting it so it was a complete
surprise and I didn't help but lean
forward and start [ __ ] crying 47 when
you get to middle age and you're stoner
everything makes you [ __ ] cry but
I'll be honest with you that was [ __ ]
dope man him call him young Skywalker
like you know when I was a kid I saw
that movie and that's the mentor-student
relationship that I know other than like
what I was taught in school was from
Empire Strikes Back
you get yourself a master and the master
teaches the pupil and [ __ ] like that so
it's nice seeing those guys together and
you notice still teaching them [ __ ] 40
years on still taking them to school so
let's see there's a moment where Ray
takes off like you'd seen earlier in the
movie Luke's x-wing submerged in a
lagoon on sky land the island Skywalker
Island and up to what's called where
octo I'm not sure but anyway when you
saw it you're like oh
son I know what's gonna happen I know
what's gonna happen when he's gonna
raise that [ __ ] like you all raised his
x-wing looking fly back and fight the
[ __ ] first order but you know that's
one of the charms of this movie is that
if you think you know where it's going
they will make a decision to be like no
that's not it and they will go in a
different direction
satisfying just not the version that I
would have done you know I would have
lifted that excellent you put an x-wing
in the water you better lift it out of
the water
and I want to send to back to take on
the whole [ __ ] Empire himself like
deck number index like I feel like I
could take on the whole empire myself
[ __ ] that's why I'd have Luke do and
we kind of get that later on but in any
event he don't raise the x-plane stays
in the water but okay so just like let
me see Finn and Rose they wait did I
talk about that already
oh so after they they find they go to
Monte Carlo the casino joint and [ __ ]
like that
they found the summer I just want to
talk about they introduced the notion
that the Empire or the first order sorry
I have to keep correcting the first
order doesn't build its own weapon reek
like any army they buy it from weapons
manufacturers like Tony Stark and
[ __ ] Stark Industries and [ __ ] like
that but you don't do that no more
Obadiah Stane would probably [ __ ]
sell that [ __ ] to him so in any event
they introduced the notion of like there
are rich people in the galaxy and these
people make TIE fighters and then at one
point Benicio del Toro is like you know
they make them put a good for the bad
guys and the good guys and they show an
x-wing so apparently these people got
rich just selling you know [ __ ] the
machinery of war to both sides that's
the notion that it was never introduced
to me in the Star Wars movies when I was
kid you didn't think about this sort of
[ __ ] well you were just like who makes
these ships you know you were just like
well the Empire makes their ships and
the rebels make their ships but
apparently they bar buy their ships from
[ __ ] weapons people and I don't know
it's just weird it would have changed
the way I played Star Wars with my
figures as a kid because I could have
had whole adventures where the Emperor
is just like I would like to order four
hundred new Tie Fighters bringing them
as soon as possible
my purchase order number is you know
maybe not as fun as the oh [ __ ] but
still it would have been a way to go
there's an interesting notion though man
and of course very modern to talk about
you know a man who makes these [ __ ]
weapons
who's profiting from this war and stuff
so in any event that's going on that was
on Monaco Rey she gets off she took off
in a falcon she escaped pods off the
[ __ ] Falcon and [ __ ] a little mini
escape pod I don't know how Falcon had
one of those and she winds up on Snoke
ship her a little space coffin takes
around a Stoke ship and she's looking
through the glass and [ __ ] and there's
kylo Ren you know Fayed without the mask
anymore pretty kylo Ren his face gets
fixed up to from when she [ __ ] cut it
last movie and then she you know he
reveals some stormtroopers behind him
and they got cuffs and so you gonna take
her in to see the Emperor and stuff like
that they're on Snoke ship and emo Solo
takes her to see to see to Snoke the
motion capture madman we've been
speculating about since we saw the force
awakens like hey man who is it really is
it the Emperor come back to life is it
[ __ ] you know mace windu I saw one
theory it looks kind of like mace windu
is it you know some other Star Wars
characters and one deeply connected is
it
there's always is it who is it who isn't
connected and he's grand moff tarkin
it's none of those but it doesn't really
matter turns out really doesn't matter
going forward who [ __ ] Snoke is Snoke
reveals that he's the guy that bridged
the minds of ray and Kyle oh man and he
used kylos emo wears a [ __ ] dildo for
beers guard against him and if you know
by [ __ ] putting those two together
teaming him up and [ __ ] and he's like I
knew you try to turn each other I'm
[ __ ] the smartest [ __ ] in the galaxy
you guys [ __ ] fools he's a fool
you're a fool and you better tell me
where [ __ ] Skywalker is ma'am I'm
[ __ ] don't even tell me I'm gonna
pull it out your [ __ ] mind and then
I'm gonna [ __ ] you're gonna die
painful and [ __ ] like that so he starts
torturing Rey and stuff trying to get
information out of her meanwhile Finn
and ROS they're they after they help the
[ __ ] Tontons where are we well here
the resistance ships are running out of
gas backed with that so POE Poe Dameron
he gets all mad at he's like [ __ ] it and
he makes mutiny against
hold Oh
Laura Dern's character who Princess Leia
she's next in charge you have to
princess like a general Leia
so she's fueling up the escape pods
instead of like you know [ __ ] let's
jump or get the [ __ ] out of here she's
feeling up escape pods which are more
like ships and you know they're gonna
ban and ship and Poteau like this is
like that's your [ __ ] plan you blown
all this gas in two hours of the movie
to [ __ ] a new jump ship that's it
[ __ ] you're an idiot and makes mutiny
man him and a few others turn their guns
on [ __ ] hold oh and the others and he
takes over the [ __ ] ship but then
she's like aah
and she knocks this [ __ ] steam thing
off and she gets away and then also the
bridge gets locked out and then there's
star warring eachother a civil star war
on the resistance ship last thing they
need as the [ __ ] Empire they don't
even then first orders could just hang
back these [ __ ] would kill
themselves soon enough if they don't run
out of gas so then you know BAM the
bridge doors open and blow open and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] Princess Leia comes out of
her sickbed and and pose like what the
[ __ ] and she's a poon takes a mountain
ship so there goes the mutiny and [ __ ]
like that okay the whole thing is they
find out when he wakes up the plan all
along was to get the ship as close to
the planet crate and then the escape
pods would take off and jettison down a
crate where there used to be a rebel
base back in the day already just
sitting there waiting for that's why
they were doing the slow chase because
anywhere they jumped the Empire would
follow because they were tracking them
but the Empire don't track the little
ships tracks the main ship but I don't
couldn't track the pods so like look we
get as close to crate as possible
the pods get down to crate we get inside
the [ __ ] fort before these [ __ ]
fools know that there's nobody on the
goddamn ship to sound plan but [ __ ]
nobody bothered to tell PO you know
because he was bucked down and rank
bumped down and ranking [ __ ] you know
you just save a lot of time in the movie
if you like popes but you know the idea
is like he's hot shot always wants to
blow [ __ ] up and these women are like
hey man we got a plan [ __ ] and
so you know after after Prince's lair
general Leia Organa gives him the plan
he's like oh I didn't [ __ ] know that
was your plan I thought [ __ ] hole
dough was turning evil man and he was
she was like no man she was trying to
[ __ ] keep the light right she's not
interested in credit for herself she's
kind of keep the light alive and should
keep the fire burning the [ __ ] spark
we are the spark that will you
be the resistance whatever [ __ ] the line
is so it's kind of cool moment for her
at where you know she's gonna go down
with the ship hold though she says to
lay alike by mannequin you know I'm
gonna go down with the ship you go this
is it
this is the moment you know I've been
waiting for and stuff like that and so
it's kind of beautiful where are we at
now let's see back on Snoke ship all up
in Snoke he tells kylo Ren you got a
[ __ ] lightsaber that girl than death
that's your [ __ ] job and instead kylo
Ren's like all right well while [ __ ]
snoke's telling her it's like you know
what's gonna happen I'm gonna tell you
the next [ __ ] ten minutes your
[ __ ] life before you die starts
telling her everything and then this
guy's gonna [ __ ] run you through the
lightsaber because that's who I am
[ __ ] Snoke and then I'm gonna find
Skywalker man [ __ ] kill him and blah
blah blah
he's pretty powerful you could see him
whipping people whipping her around the
room there's one funny bit where she
goes for the lightsabers Luke's
lightsaber sitting on the armors chair
and just like lukovitch other Jedi went
for it and [ __ ] and got the true and it
went honest [ __ ] she goes for it but it
goes all the way around her and comes
back and like walks her in the head and
then goes back to [ __ ] Stokes arm so
the chair or the arm of his charities
like come on [ __ ] Snoke don't you get
it that don't mean [ __ ] because as he's
sitting there telling her what's gonna
happen he's like my young apprentice and
[ __ ] like that having his Emperor and
Return of the Jedi moment kylo Ren
sitting there listening to him and kylo
Ren is you know Ben solo he's [ __ ]
emo as [ __ ] to begin with now doubly
mochas is like my [ __ ] best friend
and boss literally used me told me that
[ __ ] he [ __ ] hoodwinked me like I
thought me and this girl were connected
and he [ __ ] used me and he called me
weak like right in front of her dog des
you see him get mad and he's likes his
lightsaber like his looks like he's
gonna jam [ __ ] you know Ray and Hart
or whatever but meanwhile you see his
hand doing some force [ __ ] to the side
like some of this [ __ ] and when that
happened I was like nah cuz I knew it
was coming we all did and you see the
lightsaber
that's on the arm of the chair turned
towards Snoke man and then finally you
know Snoke as he's telling ray what's
gonna happen he's like and then I won't
tell him to turn on your lights and I
strike down your greatest enemy and
[ __ ] homeboy goes like and Tolleson
you here Wow and the [ __ ] lightsaber
turns on into Snoke and you're like what
did I mean it's one thing for him
tres no but like you don't usually kill
the Emperor to the third [ __ ] movie
what's going on and then he goes and the
[ __ ] pulls the lightsaber you know
the force so it cuts this [ __ ] in half
to Stokes Snoke the sequel part one and
two and then [ __ ] ray catches the
lightsaber Snoke [ __ ] falls in half
then all his evil Red Guards like you
know who are awfully [ __ ] slow to
react or like what what and they start
attacking and there's a slow moment slow
slow mo moment where our [ __ ] two
heroes now kylo Ren and right together
fighting these [ __ ] man that was dope
really dope real cool they're their
champion I said some people online goes
well greatest lightsaber battles in the
movie I mean I don't we actor you know
of all the movies absolutely but the one
in Star Wars kind of weak to old men
like Ben Kenobi and David Prowse kind of
hitting each other with sticks one of
the greatest of course is it would be
quite on Jin versus and and Ben Kenobi
versus Darth Maul I was [ __ ]
fantastic
this one was cool but it was kind of
like a wide shot that pushed in or a two
shot that pulled out into wide they kind
of ride and let them fight in the room
you know and look cool but it wasn't
like oh my god Mach mind-bending was
[ __ ] cutting that [ __ ] in half with
the lightsaber it took me back to my
childhood when I was kidding I'll return
the Jedi and Luke did that moment where
he got the [ __ ] lightsaber and then
he wields it up here seeing and then he
goes to come down I always bugged me
that like if he didn't grab it he could
just spun around while it was kept going
and then he the back of his blades going
through the back of [ __ ] chair and
cutting him in half I promise you I
swear to you guys have that discussion
with my high school girlfriend all the
time was why didn't he just swing around
the chair and cut from behind and she
was like why do you think about that
[ __ ] I was like I don't know might make
a great career one day they did it they
did that moment essentially cut him in
fat he didn't go behind the chair but
they cut him in half in his own [ __ ]
Emperor chairman was dope and then they
start fighting with each other and
they've taken out the guards and [ __ ]
who have really big outfits for fighting
I don't know if I put that much paper
and drapery and [ __ ] if I had to move
around quick but they're supposed to be
elite but not a leap because they could
take it out she cuts one of like one
point there's guy holding the lights
get close to her face then she [ __ ]
drops it drops down catches light sever
cuts [ __ ] legs out and then [ __ ]
cuts him in half like it was fantastic I
like she knows how to use that [ __ ]
lightsaber that right gray a drop of
Golden Sun so is that was pretty dope
scene and at the end of it you know
she's like hurry up man we can select
the resistance ships well problem is
meanwhile while that's going on the the
first order
well [ __ ] now I got to take you back
Finn and rose and Benicio del Toro space
Fenster he's like what the [ __ ] they get
on the ship
the Snoke ship as promised God gets him
out of [ __ ] and then just as they're
about to go in the chamber where you
shut down the [ __ ] tracking device P
room all the cops show up space call the
Imperial that first order shows up and
including a [ __ ] evil bb-8 bizarro
bb-8 who's been watching my [ __ ] like
more harm because they're just like
Imperials and to dress up bb-8 they
empty the garbage cans tuck it on top of
them which was kind of a cute idea when
we were kids people are always like that
r2d2 looks like a garbage can so it was
kind of cute notion but anyway they get
[ __ ] caught so they don't even
accomplish their mission and then you're
like what the [ __ ] and then suddenly
space fence term ends I can flip yaaaa
I flipped out and he flips on him and
[ __ ] sells sells out his buddies man
the usual suspect himself sells out his
[ __ ] buddies for money and you know
[ __ ] Finn's like hey man like you
can't be that way and life life be
enough sucks like that and he's like
maybe you're right
and it [ __ ] off like that's it Benicio
is gone from the movie so they're caught
and all sudden captain phasma shows up
it's the Boba Fett of this [ __ ] you
know is played by Brienne of Tarth from
Game of Thrones
and she's like FN 2 to 8 1 7 whatever
his number isn't [ __ ] and so she decides
they're gonna execute him like fire
blasters too good for these fools we're
gonna use a [ __ ] the space cheese
grater a laser cheese grater to [ __ ]
cut him in half and they're about to
kill him and rose and [ __ ] like that so
everybody is on the edge of their seats
meanwhile they found out the first order
what the resistance was doing getting
these little ships away
from the big ship and they're like [ __ ]
it I target those little ships and start
blowing these [ __ ] out the sky BAM
they're taking out [ __ ] ships left
and right Leia and poll around a ship
with like [ __ ] their ships are going
down all around the resistance is [ __ ]
at this point and so although laura dern
is on the big ship and she's and the
moment they cut to her i was like oh my
god oh my god please do this and they
[ __ ] did it one of the greatest
moments in any Star Wars movie admiral
hauled oh emmalin hold out turns the
[ __ ] ship around and goes light speed
through Stokes vehicle never seen that
in Star Wars movie that and as they set
up for it I was like I said I want to
kiss Rian Johnson and his [ __ ]
co-writing buddy I was like you got ma
[ __ ] that's good god damn it that's good
second viewing I had this feeling of
like would have been better if Leia did
it you know what I'm saying she worked
their whole life fighting the rebels and
[ __ ] like that what a way to go out that
would have been it's tough but hey man
that's quibbles that's my version of
Star Wars there's nobody ever gonna see
in this version I was wholly satisfied
by her [ __ ] turn that ship around and
like yeah and they do it like with no
sounds classy as [ __ ] man soundless cuz
in space no one can hear you [ __ ]
scream and so just Rockets through and
[ __ ] stoked snoke's ship gets like
decimated so meanwhile that saves the
resistance they get down to crank and it
saves Finn Andros you know cuz the
little [ __ ] the explosion [ __ ] tosses
everybody around except phasma's like
you FN 22 whatever you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and they have their fight and which
you've seen in the trailer and they
battle to like you know near standstill
and then she he [ __ ] hits her with
some [ __ ] you know across the face or
mass break so he could see her eye and
feel like they look it's Breanna Tarth
somebody tell Jamie the King's lair
here's buddy's here and so then she
falls back down a [ __ ] floor into the
fire and presumably she's dead but you
know his [ __ ] Star Wars so maybe she
comes back with more armor next time and
[ __ ] like burnt to a crisp but just you
know they [ __ ] dude they did for
Darth Vader maybe they'll do
her so maybe she's not gone maybe she is
but I'll tell you what man smoke getting
sliced in half captain phasma getting
iced all felt like [ __ ] you force
awakens like again those are big
fundamental parts of those movies and
suddenly in this movie it's just like we
undid it we don't need it a goose you
know suddenly gone so it was it was kind
of weird to see it's to see both Snoke
go and and that other thing but whatever
so let me see snoke's dead now his ship
is trashed the whole dome maneuver saves
a fin and rose as we said and they
[ __ ] fight and stuff with phasma
after they kill all of smokes elite
guards ray says to kylo we can [ __ ]
save the resistance man we got shut
these ships downs before a [ __ ] smoke
smoke ship gets smoked by hauled oh and
you can see all sudden he's like no I
don't want to do that he's like let him
die let the free resistance die let the
first door to die [ __ ] burn it all
ground to the ground [ __ ] our families
[ __ ] everything else he's gone it's just
you and me like we can rebuild the
galaxy together as father and son it's
that kind of moment where he's like [ __ ]
all this let's join forces and then you
know she's like oh please Ben don't do
this really nice moment for Daisy
Ridley's she's like Ben don't like you
can she had a friend and for a moment
somebody who understands her she wasn't
alone in this [ __ ] world and you know
he saved her life she saved his life and
then all of a sudden you know she sees
the [ __ ] dark side poem and this
guy's just no [ __ ] good it's no good
so you know he starts to [ __ ] town or
come on man [ __ ] we could do this we
could do this we could [ __ ] we don't
need these people and [ __ ] like that and
she's like please don't don't make me do
this and they wind up force fighting
each other for Luke Skywalker's
lightsaber very symbolic and they're
holding each other and this [ __ ]
fight it was cool I like I like that you
know he [ __ ] turned like I was glad
that it's like he wasn't kylo Ren good
guy he had a moment and then all of a
sudden he was like you know [ __ ] all
this burn it all down like you know he
said something in the trailer about like
burn it down or [ __ ] kill your hate
or whatever [ __ ] kill it all kill the
past he says that at one point to to her
it's like kill the past talking about
his mom and his dad and [ __ ] like that
so you're like I all right he was with
her now he's against her now it's back
to star war and [ __ ] like that
so they start [ __ ] fighting let's say
it ends in a big explosion a big
explosion they're fighting for that
lightsaber and force [ __ ] explosion
between him or some such [ __ ]
so Hawkes comes in the room later on
where they were fighting in the
Emperor's chamber he sees the [ __ ]
Emperor the the snoke's chamber and he
sees his boss [ __ ] cut in half and
[ __ ] his legs fall off the chair and so
he has a moment there was a really cool
moment man whether we're gonna let the
Weasley brother [ __ ] kill kylo Ren
like he sees him out cold on the floor
and he reaches into his jacket like I'm
on ice this [ __ ] fool but instead
kylo Ren wakes up he's like where is she
where's rey and he's like she took
snoke's escape ship and [ __ ] off and
he's like oh we're going to crate we
know where they're [ __ ] going
cratenbarrel we're going down to the
[ __ ] planet we're gonna kill these
[ __ ] rebels for once and for others
resistance sorry Chameli once and for
all I'm [ __ ] going down there like
we're all going let's go and you know
he's the Huck's is like hey man our boss
is dead like that's it I was in it for
him for Snoke and [ __ ] homeboy like
wrecks him against a wall as if to be
like chokes um he's a gay and you know
does the force choke on music alright
you're world [ __ ] and suddenly he's in
charge suddenly the new Supreme Leader
is kylo Ren no longer Snoke so what
happens Ben Huck's is all Huck's you
know [ __ ] after his who's the boss
moment he learns the boss is [ __ ]
kylo Ren kylo Ren's like we're going
down the [ __ ] killer resistance
uncrate at this point in the movie I was
like holy [ __ ] man like like I thought
the movie was wrapping up I was like
this is [ __ ] insanely satisfying Wow
I'm what a [ __ ] thrill ride then I
sit there going wait a second I didn't
see no gorilla walkers yet I didn't see
that planet with all the red stripes and
[ __ ] like wait what then I realized
there's like another half hour of this
movie to go they stay packed a lot of
movie into this it felt like watching a
season of a TV show man
not in a bad way just like there's a lot
of fun it's dense there's a lot of
[ __ ] story man you get your money's
worth on this [ __ ] movie
you know remembering you're only paying
what [ __ ] 8 to 12 dollars
I got felt like I got my money's worth
so at any point at any event I'm create
the resistance sets up shop in an old
rebel base with giant metal doors man
and a first order ship races at the base
followed by attacking Tie Fighters but
it's really rose and finn and bb-8 they
escaped you know from the [ __ ] from
the from the first order in a you know
you know what looked like the the ship
that they stole and in Return of the
Jedi you know the Emperor ship of Darth
Vader shut how those thought was the
Emperor ship not any event they stay
[ __ ] get through the front doors and
you have ones like Kilowog nogs us don't
shoot and so they're like alright man
get ready cuz shits about to happen and
you know Leia is looking out when
somebody's looking out lady's looking
out over she's wearing a turtleneck and
she's looking out and she sees some [ __ ]
like the ship coming at him and stuff
then they realized like the first orders
landed they got walkers they got these
big-ass gorilla walkers which are snow
walkers but with longer arms then they
also have they're setting up this thing
they're called a battering ram can Laser
battering ram kept battering ram cannon
I think is what I wrote down they
described it as miniaturized Death Star
technology proving once again these
movies can not get the [ __ ] away from
the Death Star even if it's not in the
movie to like but this is just like the
Death Star
you know it's this thing they turn on
and it's gonna cut through that [ __ ]
metal door so the resistance gets any
ships they have together and there's
mostly these crop-dusting little ships
and [ __ ] like that for crate it's a salt
planet it's all covered in white so
every time like ships move the [ __ ]
white spreads and you see the red
underneath or vice versa it's very
visually stunning when they have a crate
battle on crate looks beautiful sparking
and moving so they send these fighters
out to take on the gorilla walkers and
maybe take out the [ __ ] battering ram
cannon and you know get killed because
they're not even in fighter jets and
[ __ ] but instead the [ __ ] Falcon your
childhood comes in to save ya and I'm
just like you know Han Solo at the end
of Star we're clear
good that was blow this thing got here
ray and Chewie take the TIE fighters
lead the TIE fighters off in the Falcon
which gives the guys on the ground which
is like Poe and rose and and Finn and
the rest of the resistance chance to get
in at those guns they're getting picked
off left and right and suppose like we
ain't gonna do it we can't do it now
it's Finn's
turn to be Poe where he's like we're
doing it I'm too close and he hates the
[ __ ] first order because he was a
stormtrooper he's a gamma Braun stopping
his [ __ ] and he's like post-op and he
[ __ ] turns his comlink off you don't
want to know about roses like Paul but
then then don't [ __ ] do this and Finn
is just racing at that [ __ ] gun man
and then you like you legit you're
buying it you're like oh my god they're
gonna [ __ ] kill another character
smoked them and instead at the last
second rows of [ __ ] BAM blast his ship
out of the way before it blows up into
the eye of the the battering ram ken and
their ships go flying he gets out of
Chevy runs over to her and she's like
half dead and he's like why did you do
why did you stop me and she has like one
of the most beautiful moments of the
movie and probably one of the most
eloquent takedowns or rationales behind
worth of logic behind war and any I
thought was eloquent I wrote the [ __ ]
down where is it man
she says goddamn it where did I write it
she says oh she goes she goes I saved
you he goes why'd you stop me and she
goes I saved you and she says that's how
we're gonna win not by fighting what we
hate by saving what we love simple
sentiment beautifully stated beautifully
acted i-i've cried during that moment to
this that's you know you forget Star
Wars so it's like we come to watch the
warp these characters in the movie like
we don't want this [ __ ] is horrible but
we're gonna do it and not because we're
like [ __ ] the enemy is because we love
the people that were protecting and
stuff like that really really [ __ ]
wonderful summation of why anybody
fights
I would hope okay the resistance set out
of stress called but nobody's [ __ ]
coming man after all these years last
stands alone they're gonna die on crate
you know and there's not many left it
all get picked off in space like you
know looks like maybe a couple hundred
[ __ ] resistance fighters left and
they're all gonna be decimated because
kylo ren's like take them all out he's
on his [ __ ]
ship hovering over the [ __ ] grill the
walkers yelling at Hawkes I could do
this do that and so even though Leigh is
alone and mrs. Bennett happens dude we
waited the whole [ __ ] movie for this
but Luke shows up man the resistance
sent out the distress signal nobody's
coming
Luke shows up Luke and Leia have this
emotional reunion it's another of the
best scenes in the movie for me because
there they are man there's the original
two star warriors together man again he
changed the course of his destiny for
this woman years back he saw a little
bitty over and he's like I'm gonna
changed my whole [ __ ] life to join
this fight you know part of it was like
she's pretty and they found out they
were related now he's gonna give her he
sits down he talks to her about [ __ ]
you know hey man how you been and she's
like you know she's like I changed my
hair he's like I know and then he gives
her han solo space dice you staying in
the [ __ ] Falcon and he says you know
nobody's ever really gone because he
hasn't really talked to her about Han
yet and stuff like that and he's been
disconnected by from the force that's
why maybe he don't know that Honda's
dead but so she gives her the dice they
have this kind of really warm scene and
then he gets kisses his sister's
forehead is really lovely and you know
the only thing is like of course I'm
like more scenes with Kari and mark but
I was happy with the scene I got then he
gets up and he heads out and you're like
oh my god are they gonna do it like is
he literally gonna do what he said he
wouldn't do is he gonna pay Stella no
first order for the [ __ ] laser sword
this could be the greatest moment and
sent him a [ __ ] history may walk
sidewalks best c-3po and he gives him a
wing Threepio get [ __ ] on left-to-right
in all these [ __ ] movies everyone
loves in r2d2 nobody [ __ ] [ __ ] and
likes Threepio it's always getting
[ __ ] [ __ ] so it winks at 3pl that's
all Threepio gets after all that [ __ ] r2
he gets like a real emotional
conversation with three peelers like
what up golden rod and then [ __ ]
heads out man for a moment I wrote it's
one of the most powerful images in any
Star Wars movie ever made we are over
the shoulder and behind the man from
Tatooine
man was once a farm boy as he faces down
a slew of Walker's and giant spaceship
they're kidding me is a moment that
becomes instantly legendary is almost
instantly legendary as when the Darth
Vader minute at the end of [ __ ] rogue
one it sums up everything we've always
thought about Star Wars as kids Luke
Skywalker against all the [ __ ] bad
guys and there it is summed up in one
beautiful [ __ ] image so [ __ ] emo
Ren is like I want every gun pointed at
that [ __ ] man and fire and they open
[ __ ] fire and it's [ __ ] glorious
because you know what's gonna happen I
don't care if you've never seen a movie
before in your life you know he you know
what's gonna happen when the [ __ ]
smoke clears and the shooting stops BAM
unscathed Luke Skywalker gives him one
of these like come on is that all you've
gotten [ __ ] glorious glorious it was
fantastic and then [ __ ] kylo ren's
like drop me down to the planet I gotta
fight this fool myself and I'm like
we're gonna have a [ __ ] old timey
old-timers fight just like Ben Kenobi
[ __ ] fought Darth Vader and [ __ ] Luke
Skywalker old timey Grizzly Adams Luke's
coward we're gonna fight young Darth
Vader have a turn ooh Vader kylo Ren
Vader foe Vader poser Vader Darth poser
whatever the [ __ ] so we're gonna get it
we're gonna get we're gonna see Mark
Hamill [ __ ] wield the lightsaber for
the first time since you know [ __ ]
Jay and Silent Bob's shrink back he's
gonna be holding a laser sword and
fighting with it so I was [ __ ] ready
for this [ __ ] man he ducks kylo is
attacking [ __ ] he's talking to him he's
just like hey man if you kill me I'm
gonna be with you forever
just like your father and in that moment
I was like they're gonna show Han Hans
gonna be a force ghost we're gonna see
it [ __ ] that didn't happens don't worry
don't don't get your hopes up um he just
mentions it to him he's just like your
dad I know you killed your [ __ ]
father you piece of [ __ ] kylo ren's my
god he goes to attack him a few times
can't hit [ __ ] Luke and then all of a
sudden he you know he [ __ ] the kylo
Ren is like I'm pissed and he goes to
[ __ ] run Luke through with his
lightsaber and he stabs [ __ ] Luke
through the heart but it does nothing
and you're like are they saying he's you
know [ __ ] unkillable what the [ __ ]
what's going on and [ __ ] and then all of
a sudden kylo Ren realizes Luke's not
there it is a force casting like a like
astral projection of himself he's forced
to himself across space and time into a
like a you know the projection it's a
forced projection he was never there he
wasn't there in the room with Leia
kissing her they reveal Luke hovering on
a rock back on skywalker island scotland
octo and he's you know [ __ ] holy
projecting himself across galaxies to be
there and that his PO in the base is
just like oh [ __ ] he's just buying his
time he can't [ __ ] defeat the first
orders before he realizes the force
projection he's like he's buying his
time so we get out of here and he got in
here so there's got to be another way
out and then they notice a way where is
all that crystal Fox's at and all the
crystal foxes is scattered there's one
and he goes running like follow that
[ __ ] Fox and so they follow him to
the back of the base and you know
there's there animals are getting out to
little holes in the rock and [ __ ] and
they're like no person can get through
this and so ray lands her ship you know
cuz she's been tracking the people and
stuff and so she lands a ship near it
and she gets out and sees that the
entryway or the exit is covered in
[ __ ] rocks and there's one moment in
training with Luke Skywalker where he's
just like the force is not about like
[ __ ] moving rocks and [ __ ] like that
and so it's a it's a sweet callback
because she looks at all these rocks and
she's like the force is not about moving
rocks or something like that and so you
know you realized oh [ __ ] she's gonna
move these [ __ ] rocks you're gonna
see the full power of the [ __ ] force
at her fingertips and [ __ ] and sure
enough as Luke is you know talking to to
kylo Ren in the battle before he reveals
his force ghost and [ __ ] he's like I'm
not gonna be the last Jedi I'm not the
last Jedi and then he indicate that
Ray's last Jedi she's [ __ ] making all
the rocks float and everybody's like
holy [ __ ] and they all escape and get
onto the Falcon and that's when Luke
says to kylo Ren see you around kid and
he [ __ ] four spades out and [ __ ] see
you know we're gonna see him as a force
ghost in the next movie he's gonna play
a role I saw people online be like is
that it he literally says see you around
kid so he'll be back for sure
meanwhile they cut to okto where Luke
you know [ __ ] collapses after doing
that and remember just like kylo a told
ray that would destroy you if you tried
to [ __ ] talk across the
you tried to force project yourself
across the galaxy it [ __ ] destroys
Luke Skywalker and you could tell that
he's dying and stuff and he climbs up
onto the rock and they give mark this
kind of sweet beautiful moment where he
there I don't know if it's meant that
the planet has twin suns or it's a
reflection or something but just like on
Tatooine when he was a boy and he looked
up in the sky and saw the twin suns and
there's sweeping John Williams queue you
know pondering ones future you don't
have to be a boy who saw Star Wars in
1977 gonna be anybody who's ever seen
that movie we're never seeing that movie
and know the feeling of looking up
looking out looking somewhere and just
going where am i what do I fit in what
am I supposed to do when does my life
begin and here's the end of that moment
like 40 years later it's him going I
know where I've been I know what I've
done I Know Who I am now more than ever
and I'm at peace and I'm reconnected
with the force again and maybe it's time
and he lets himself go and just like how
Yoda died and then disappeared and the
blanket fell Luke dies and they do like
you know it dissolve and boom the
blanket [ __ ] falls almost as if it
was the 70s or 80s like you could have
done a special effect where he's like
literally disappears but they just kind
of dissolved as classy and that's it
Luke Skywalker [ __ ] dies now would I
have done that no but now I'm not saying
it's wrong that they did it I understand
what they did but I've been having
discussions with people and I just this
is the one thing I stumble onto is there
and I can't maybe I missed it I saw it
twice was there a reason he physically
couldn't be there like maybe it was
really like you know he can't get there
they explain whatever [ __ ] but if I was
in charge I would have sent him there
like he would have been there in
physical person in that moment we're all
the [ __ ] ships bear down and shoot
him they can't get him because he's a
[ __ ] Jedi Master he's just like you I
would have loved it if he deflected each
shot into all the [ __ ] Walker's till
everyone was [ __ ] dead except him and
kylo Ren and even if they had to have
him die and he gets killed by kylo Ren
man at least we would have seen master
Jedi Jedi Master Luke's ghagra this was
our hero we grew up with this kid and
and to see him [ __ ] just be like
equivalent of the Yoda fight in the
prequels where Yoda takes on Dooku and
you're like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
which I just realized now as a precursor
to the Darth Vader one minute rogue one
man we did see somebody cool go apeshit
and be young with the lightsaber Yoda
and then they did it for Darth Vader
would have been awesome in my version
that's what Luke Skywalker had done not
unhappy with the version I saw it's just
I wouldn't have I don't I wouldn't have
done that and I still don't understand
why couldn't leave maybe somebody knows
like you know hey there's a reason he
says seeing if anybody knows no nobody
nobody seems to have an answer I thought
maybe there was something in there I
thought he chose to join the force for
the next generation somebody suggested
III don't I don't know he's not but
anyway look didn't die like you know as
he tells us nobody's ever really gone he
tells Leia
he just went one with the force you know
just like Ben Kenobi he you know
remember the [ __ ] Vader comes through
if you strike me down I should become
more powerful than you could possibly
imagine and he [ __ ] goes to cut him
and then the robe drops then Vader you
know puts his foot in the Robo
motherfuckas his body Ben Kenobi became
one with the force that you could do
that if your Jedi Master I'm told I
don't know for a fact
Yoda became one with the force Luke
himself becomes one with the force but
physically he is no longer so
technically that is dead but yes so
let's see where are we with this ray
gets all the resistance onto the Falcon
they take off let me see Leia and Raya
no Luke's gone they both feel it you
know they have a conversation we're like
he's gone she's like I [ __ ] know he's
my brother you fool and Luke tells I
mean Leia
you know Leia Leia tells me see he died
oh look but Leia says or Ray says like
he died I felt peace like he was a a
sense of peace like he wasn't even dying
a [ __ ] you know yeah lightsaber in the
head or cutting a half like [ __ ]
smoke and [ __ ] he was just sitting on a
rock he was like there's a little black
spot on the Suns today and then he was
just no there it wasn't there in him
that was a kind of peaceful hey man if
that's how I can go in this life force
you know [ __ ] ghost me out of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't want no pain he
didn't look like he didn't have any
either Rose is getting fixed up by the
resistance Finn brought her in and stuff
so she's not dead ray finally meets Poe
Finn took her and I say Finn before I
always confused spinning buh-buh-buh
meets right for the first time we need
they didn't meet each other in the last
movie and [ __ ] like that
ray you know on the on the crate
reunites with with Finn and I was very
sweet because they started this
adventure kind of together and and so
when she sees him and he sees her they
like genuinely a genuine affection for
one another deep hug and she is really
warm moment in the movie and any of that
they're all everybody's now Princess
Leia general layer again they're all on
the bridge of the [ __ ] or you know
yeah I guess the bridge I don't know
what you call of the Millennium fact
they're all on the Falcon together and
[ __ ] living to fight another day
and you know talking about like the
resistance begins like Luke said it and
he's just like the [ __ ] resistance
isn't dead it's born anew today as are
the Jedi for I won't be the last Jedi
and his [ __ ] ray and [ __ ] and they
are the spark that will ignite the flame
that will burn down the first order so
they didn't kill him at all they've been
the first order drove them to the brink
of non-existence but they're like there
are others out there nobody answered our
[ __ ] beacon jerks but like you know I
feel it there are people out there man
soon there will be an uprising and [ __ ]
and they could literally end on the
Millennium Falcon but I have been a
minute with credits and [ __ ] but instead
they go to back to the canto bright
planet they we're taking the candle
bright where we see three kids the
stable kids who when they let the horses
out on canto bright the stable kid at
one point was like I'm gonna turn on the
alarm she's like dome and we're with the
rebels or the resistance and the kid
shows he has a resistance ring and [ __ ]
so it's it's reached out across the
galaxy everyone hates the [ __ ] first
order but they're kids I can't [ __ ]
do anything except in this instance they
don't [ __ ] tell on the adults who
then get away so you cut back to the
stables and you see the three kids
playing Star Wars with off-brand Star
Wars figures and [ __ ] not licensed
off-brand and like in there speaking a
foreign language side by jebadiah Luke
Skywalker and you know you realize it
was
moving you're like oh [ __ ] like look
these movies have to go somewhere it
can't always be like the Skywalker
family [ __ ] they gotta extend and expand
the universe so what they're saying is
they're other force sensitives out there
it's not just [ __ ] Skywalker's and
[ __ ] like that
and at one point when kylo Ren is
talking to Ray he's just like you know
you've always wondered about your past I
know about your past and you've seen it
too and you know you're not [ __ ]
related to anybody
your parents were [ __ ] junkies junk
dealers and [ __ ] like that and they left
you on that [ __ ] planet they weren't
coming back you're not even a part of
this is really bullying you're not a
part of this story he says he says you
mean nothing to anybody and he says
except to me like you could genuinely
tell he cares about ectasia power and
[ __ ] like that
so but then you know [ __ ] things went
south with them but that was incredible
that in another [ __ ] you force awakens a
moment where you're like who is Ray's
parents the lineage of Ray the mystery
box that is Ray has now been solved and
it's like Ray's just somebody just like
anybody out some [ __ ] like that not part
of the Skywalker lineage not Ben
Kenobi's kid or whatever the [ __ ]
force-sensitive just like this kid at
the end of the movie you know they're
playing and [ __ ] and then their boss
comes in big [ __ ] creatures brah
and they [ __ ] scatter and the idea is
like go back to work so little boy goes
outside and there's a broom leaning on a
wall and he reaches for it the broom
just goes into his hand not even big
across the room just very like me a
couple inches to boot into his hand but
you look huh it's kids [ __ ] force
offense sensitive and he's sweeping on
the ground then he looks up at the stars
and he opens up his resistance ring and
[ __ ] like that and you close on that
kid's face the future you know the
resistance goes on there he's diseased
the day he's not the spark they would
spark but he's gonna ignite this fire
the only way you end on that movie with
this [ __ ] strange kid I think is that
must be where Ryan's trilogy goes it
must be predicated on maybe that kid
himself and we're gonna go off on that
adventure you know cuz they said Ryan
Johnson's gonna do his own trilogy
that's not part of the saga and has
nothing to do scott walker's so maybe
that's it he laid a pretty big seed for
where he's taking it maybe we will
follow that boy on his adventure or
something like that so in any of that
there it is man I saw the movie twice
first time I was beside myself I was all
delighted second time I went back which
I enjoyed very much but that's
the you know the [ __ ] writer-director
start kicking in that's not even
writer-director because I would never
make a movie this good on any [ __ ]
level like I like watching these movies
I could never make something like this
so that's not me going I could do this
[ __ ] better but what happened on back to
second town like anybody else I'm like
oh well now I could see the strings and
like it had never occurred to me in the
first viewing that Luke literally could
have been on crepe he didn't have to
force project himself you know at first
when I saw it I was like alright on and
when they revealed he ain't really there
I was like huh that's interesting I
wonder what I can do with that
information and then when I watch the
second time I was like man I see no good
reason why he literally couldn't bet on
that planet himself like pew pew pew pew
just [ __ ] fight and [ __ ] off so you
know that's my big that's my big chance
I'm gonna critique I enjoyed the [ __ ]
out of else eat again I'll be watching
this movie until I die one day but I
would I wouldn't have Luke be there man
it was majestic standing standing there
watch him stand there against the whole
first word of this old man
and to let him [ __ ] Skywalker and
leashed oh [ __ ]
they didn't do that in any event I done
the movie a lot there's stuff that I had
problems with I saw some people online
were like he's [ __ ] chill for this
[ __ ] I ain't a shill nobody pays me to
like Star Wars I you know I wish I could
get paid to like Star Wars I'm almost
close to figuring that out but I haven't
figured that out yet I like it cuz I
like it I like it cuz I grew up with a
[ __ ] you know I like it because love now
they make [ __ ] the [ __ ] faces and
[ __ ] on it and whatnot I always bought
that [ __ ] when I was a kid beaten by a
[ __ ] chef boyardee Star Wars [ __ ]
noodles and stuff I love these Star Wars
movies they are my mythology you know
not mine somebody else's but you know I
enjoy bunch that being said of course
I'm in the bag for movies like that
don't mean I can't look at a movie and
be like objectively like no I don't know
value like that moment [ __ ] but I like
the movie a lot a whole lot
I don't gonna like it's here or there
I've been the rankings give me a little
time to digest and think about where it
is but first time I sat there and
watched that movie is well the best
times I had in a movie theater in the
last year if not the last five [ __ ]
10 years and the second time I watched I
still had a good time watching it with
my buddy he was just like this is the
star war likea now he was [ __ ]
transfixed and [ __ ] but
it is last Jedi go out and see it we're
almost an hour and a half the review is
almost as long as the movie no it's not
because the movie is two and a half
hours long so this review is an hour an
hour shorter than the actual movie I
don't know what that says about me or
the movie but anyway last Jedi kids
thanks for hanging out while I've talked
about it and [ __ ] like that
highlight of the movie for me though
hands down oddly enough is Luke and r2d2
that hit me right in the [ __ ] core I
was like this is why we're here we're on
this journey cuz him and that little
droid met so sweet
I love these movies I hope they keep
making them till the day I die and guess
what I have no choice they were gonna
keep making him so go out and see last
Jedi kids congrats to Rian Johnson and I
forget the name of his co-writer and
everyone that worked on the movie I
thought it was [ __ ] whoo congrats to
Mark like you know holy [ __ ] man
more screen time for Mark Hamill's
always a great thing great to see him as
Luke again sad wonderful scene carry gun
but sad that like that said uh uh you
know the kids I thought were great Daisy
Ridley's really come into her own and
stuff compelling lead the guy who plays
Poe was named Oscar [ __ ] fantastic I
love that actor and then to his carries
a lot of emotional weight in this movie
for you know for the guy who was like
the runaway stormtrooper and and the new
characters like Rose really well done
and stuff so they're expanding the
universe slowly be like look there's
more people in just these [ __ ] nine
[ __ ] man just like in any world and
[ __ ] like that and I'm glad about that
so there it is that's my review of the
last Jedi very long and I want to have
some buddies like what you think of it
I'm like well here's my Hauer and a half
response go see it as soon as you can
folks there you go that's it I'm gonna
take off may the force be with you I'm
gonna go home I'm gonna sit here and eat
my [ __ ] pop chips not even a
commercial do please to be free in it
there's a prop so I kept holding it up
like that alright thanks for hanging out
folks may the force be with you
[Music]
you